[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des coureurs qui se rassemblent aux
aurores il y en a dans le monde entier
mais ce matin là à quel timbre de dix
mille sportifs se sont retrouvés pour
trois courses 21 10 et 5 km sur la
thématique du chemin de l' esclavage
nous avons une histoire qui est commune
[Musique]
le département partenaire de cette 23e
édition de la célèbre challenge a amené
les meilleurs réunionnais du 10 km vous
le savez le sport fait le lien entre les
peuples avec toute cette ambiance qui a
ici on est très heureux d'être présent
et des dames est à voir des réunionnais
qui participe à cette course
en plus il ya des idées des jeunes des
aigrettes qui sont là aussi qu'ils vont
pas tous hippiques qui vont faire les 5
[Musique]
km à 7,1 c'est très important pour nous
celui de la réunion mais les esclaves
partage des racines communes avec ceux
de l'arrière 3 à commémorer le rôle des
esclaves pour la construction de la
merveilleuse ville du cap et de la
réserve à l'est
un départ sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville où mandela a fait son premier
discours après sa sortie de prison le
district 6 ou les noirs furent expulsés
les écoles pour métis le parlement le
musée de l'esclavagé les immeubles du
gouvernement dans les quartiers
d'affaires
l'histoire est ici extrêmement présents
même au milieu d'une ue speaker jochen
entouré de la montagne de la table ou
encore de la tête de lion la ville offre
aux sportifs ce qu'elle a de plus beau
et surtout du dénivelé
[Musique]
niveau très très haut
bon coup en traître et juin un mur et
j'ai blessé ni à la réunion en afrique
du sud et meurent mais c'est évidemment
bien cherbourg
superman superbes paysages une superbe
ambiance tout du long
magnifique finish à tous les réunionnais
dans le top 10 et trois podiums sur 3000
participants à l'épreuve le contrat est
bien rempli le lien est également fait
avec le mouvement sportif un partenariat
avec le club organisateur est en cours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
compris que la suite de ce lien autour
de l' esclavage aura lieu en décembre à
la réunion un rappel musical d'exception
étaient au programme
[Musique]
ans